bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi alger
replonge dans le terrorisme de masse
deux attentats simultanés à la voiture
piégée en fait entre 22 et 62 morts la
branche locale d'al qaïda est montré du
doigt
l'assemblée nationale en ébullition pour
accueillir le colonel kadhafi de
nombreux élus ont boycotté sa visite à
découvrir ce soir un entretien exclusif
avec le numéro un libyen
il répond sur le terrorisme les droits
de l'homme et l'évolution de son pays il
n'y aura finalement pas de grève à la
sncf cette semaine la cgt et la cgc
viennent de lever leur préavis
demain à la ratp le trafic devrait être
presque normale une remise à plat des
règles d'attribution des hlm la
situation financière des locataires sera
réexaminée tous les trois ans ceux qui
dépassent les plafonds devront payer
plus ou partir
un coup de théâtre dans la sphère de
montigny-lès-metz plus de vingt ans
après les faits le parquet requiert un
non-lieu pour le tueur en série francis
heaulme dans le meurtre de deux
garçonnets
enfin londres capitale de l'argent fou
la ville compte 68 milliardaire jamais
dans le monde les prêts grandes fortunes
ont été aussi nombreuse c'est le dossier
de cette édition
difficile de ne pas y voir une signature
il y avait le 11 septembre à new york le
11 mars à madrid
et bien c'est un 11 décembre qu alger a
connu l'un de ses pires attentats
les cibles sont symboliques la cour
suprême qui incarne l'autorité de l'état
et les locaux de l'onu
les deux explosions ont donc fait entre
22 et 62 morts selon les sources
philippe rochoux
la cible du premier attentat était
apparemment le conseil constitutionnel
en plein coeur d'alger
le kamikaze dans sa voiture piégée a
d'abord percuté ce bus d'étudiants qui
se rendait à la fac de droit
la plupart des victimes de ce premier
attentat sont tombés ici on avait
commencé à se dire qu'on allait passer
une bonne fête de l'aïd et on nous
ramène plus bas encore
il était 9 heures ce matin dans le
quartier de ben aknoun
dix minutes plus tard le quartier chic
de hydra est secoué par l'explosion de
la deuxième voiture piégée devant le
bâtiment du hcr le bureau des nations
unies pour les réfugiés
quatre employés de l'onu ont été tués
dix autres portées disparues j'étais
dans mon bureau avec un collègue
on a entendu une explosion loin j'ai
voulu sortir du bâtiment de l'onu
mais tout s'est effondré autour de moi
frappez les nations unies c'est la
touche internationale de cette opération
terroriste
les autorités montrent du doigt la
branche d'al qaïda les partisans de ben
laden au maghreb et pour elle il fallait
s'attendre à ce genre d'attentât après
les aveux du terrorisme arrêté au
printemps
à partir de ces arrestations que des
édifices comme le conseil
constitutionnel en particulier faisait
partie des objectifs de cette équipe
ces deux attentats qui feront peut-être
plus de 70 morts montre que le nouveau
combat d'el qaïda en algérie se situe
dans les villes plus facile à frapper et
beaucoup moins dans le maquis dont et
des actes d'une violence insensée c'est
le commentaire de la maison blanche la
france elle parle de barbarie il ya
quelques mois encore l'algérie pensait
pourtant avoir tourné la page du
terrorisme alors qui sont les poseurs de
bombes
éléments de réponse avec renaud bernard
les algérois qui déambulent sans peur
d'être fauché par une voiture piégée
l'image d'une algérie apaisé c'était il
ya quelques mois les sports de
réconciliation avec les islamistes
étaient réelles le président algérien
abdelaziz bouteflika
je risquais même a déclaré le terrorisme
est définitivement vaincu le démenti
sera cinglant en plein coeur d'alger
deux attentats à la voiture piégée fonds
33 morts un témoin filmé avec son
téléphone portable
nous sommes le 11 avril dernier mode
opératoire inédit des kamikazes se sont
fait exploser simultanément
c'est la marque d'al qaïda au maghreb
islamique
le nouveau nom des salafistes algériens
qui viennent trois mois auparavant
d'être adoubé par oussama ben laden
en réponse le pouvoir algérien va partir
à l'assaut pour démanteler les maquis et
il enregistre une victoire le numéro
deux d'al qaïda au maghreb est abattu en
kabylie le 7 octobre mais les islamistes
algériens ont déjà changé de visage
ils ont déserté les campagnes pour se
fondre à l'intérieur des villes
réparties en une multitude de petites
cellules
les voici dans un atelier de fabrication
de bombes et dans un communiqué le 23
novembre
ils vont jusqu'à défier le pouvoir
explicite des kamikazes sont près
partout à se faire exploser
aujourd'hui ils ont mis leur menace à
exécution
bonsoir samah soula vous êtes en direct
d'alger comment réagit la population
mais a voulu imaginer l'atmosphère ce
soir à g est à la peur et à la tristesse
c'est à nouveau la psychose des années
noires du terrorisme algérien avec les
vieux réflexes d alerte à la bombe
il faut des alertes à la bombe toute la
journée des rues qui se ville et puis
les algériens vous le disent nous sommes
un 11 décembre et cela est assez
important pour eux puisque l'année a été
émaillé de deux autres attentats qui ont
eu lieu un aux avril et 1 11 juillet
mais la plus grande source de peur pour
eux ce sont les cibles les quartiers
visés il ya eu le quartier de ben aknoun
qui est un quartier d'affaires avec le
conseil constitutionnel qui est tout
récent qui a été inauguré à peine deux
mois
et puis surtout le quartier d'hydra
c'est le quartier huppé d'alger c'était
le centre du hcr qui était visé mais le
quartier d'hydra abrite toutes les
ambassades l'ambassade de france se
trouve à 500 mètres à vol d'oiseau du
lieu de l'attentât il y a des sièges de
banques internationales mais il ya
surtout les maisons et résidences des
plus hauts dignitaires du régime il ya
le ministre de l'intérieur qui habite
dans ce quartier le patron de la police
le patron de la gendarmerie
c'est dire si c'est un sanctuaire qui a
été visé et touché aujourd'hui à alger
et pour les algériens cela augure du
pire
merci samah soula pour ces éléments on
en vient à la deuxième journée de la
visite du colonel kadhafi à paris
journée marquée par une visite à
l'assemblée nationale mais les critiques
sont toujours très vives et de nombreux
députés à gauche mais aussi à droite ont
décidé de boycotter la réception
thierry kurt et patrice brodeur
la garde républicaine au garde-à-vous
tambours trompettes l'assemblée
nationale déroule le tapis rouge pour
muamar kadhafi par les fenêtres les
députés de droite comme de gauche qui
boycottent la cérémonie observe de loin
le leader libyen souhaitait être reçue
dans l'hémicycle il n'aura droit qu'à la
résidence du président de l'assemblée
une heure en tout pas un dialogue non
juste une intervention devant quelques
dizaines de députés ump
moi je fais une différence entre les
pays qui continuent à se comporter en
état voyou et pays qui ont changé
cela dit je n'oublie à rien de ce
qu'était la lubie dans le passé de
nombreuses chaises sont restés vides la
visite divise y compris dans la majorité
pour l'appui micro soir certes mais la
place de kadhafi n'est pas à la semaine
nationale lorsque l'opposition
s'aperçoit qu'elle ne pourra débattre de
la présence du colonel dans ses murs
elles quittent l'hémicycle bruyamment
sur le revenu ir au micro le président
du groupe socialiste interpelle il
affirme que dans les entretiens en tête
à tête qu'il a eu avec le président de
la république qu'il n'a pas été question
des droits de l'homme alors qui dit la
vérité
nous avons le droit nous à l'assemblée
nationale exiger la vérité c'est la
cacophonie le président de l'assemblée
nationale affirme lui que la question a
bel et bien été abordé
j'ai entendu moi même le président de la
république au cours du dîner hier à
l'elysée évoqué toute l'importance qu'il
attachait aux questions des droits de
l'homme
en fin d'après-midi à l'unesco le
colonel kadhafi revenus de lui même sur
cette question avant de parler des
droits de l'homme dans les autres pays
dit il
vérifiez que les immigrés chez vous en
bénéficient le leader libyen retrouvera
le président sarkozy demain dans l'après
midi pour un dernier entretien sur fond
de polémique
et ce soir il ya quelques minutes une
manifestation contre cette visite a
rassemblé des personnalités politiques à
paris près du mur pour la fed devant
l'école militaire parmi ces
personnalités
ségolène royal bertrand delanoë ou
encore françois bayrou hier nicolas
évoqué des nicolas sarkozy évoquait des
contrats d'un montant de 10 milliards
d'euros
l'elysée a corrigé le tir aujourd'hui ce
total correspond à des intentions pas
forcément à une réalité au premier plan
airbus l'armement et le nucléaire civil
thirard griesbeck 10 milliards d'euros
rien n'est moins sûr même si l'intention
est là le colonel kadhafi semble combler
nicolas sarkozy plus réservé dans le
domaine civil 2 milliards pour l'achat
de 21 airbus
ce n'est pas une surprise l'annoncé en
avait été faite au salon du bourget en
juin dernier 2 milliards pour la
fourniture de réacteurs nucléaire pour
le dessalement de l'eau de mer la
décision avait déjà été prise l'été
dernier lors du voyage de nicolas
sarkozy en libye dans le domaine
militaire rien n'est sûr la libye a six
mois pour se décider
même si les négociations sont exclusives
c'est à dire que le colonel kadhafi ne
peut pas mettre en concurrence la france
avec d'autres pays
si les libyens disent oui ce sera pour
quatre milliards et demi d'euros soit 14
rafale la toute dernière génération
d'avions de combat que la france n'a pas
encore réussi à exporter et aussi des
hélicoptères et des blindés
et si le colonel kadhafi s'exprime
parfois on l'a entendu il y a un instant
il répond très rarement aux questions
des journalistes
je vous le disais nous avons pu le
rencontrer en exclusivité
c'était tout à l'heure avant de
l'entendre à voici d'abord la fameuse
tente bédouine qui lui sert de bureau
reportage jérôme birman stéphane
guillemot
en un siècle et demi d'existence l'hôtel
de marigny n'avais jamais vu ça trop non
sur ses pelouses la légendaire tente
bédouine de mouammar kadhafi le guide
libyen ni dort pas il séjourne en face
dans le palais et ses 3500 m² ces
appartements sont derrière ses grandes
vitres fumées
tout se déroule sous la surveillance d
amazon les escortes féminine du guide
libyen autour du brasero on prépare ses
pots dansant que l'on disposera sous la
tente c'est là que conformément à la
tradition du désert mouammar kadhafi
reçoit ses invités une tente plutôt
sobre chauffer équipés d'un téléviseur
et de toutes les chaînes internationales
le chef du protocole ils règlent tout au
millimètre avant l'arrivée à pas très
lent du guide l'entretien peut se
dérouler au milieu des volutes d'encens
bédouine dressée à l'hôtel marigny à
paris
merci de nous accueillir je sais que
vous donnez très peu d'interviews un vif
débat et le boycott de certains élus
comment réagissez vous à cette
controverse
je ne suis pas au courant lassana je
n'ai pas lu la presse n'est pas regarder
la télévision en fait vous savez je n'ai
pas beaucoup de temps pour les médias on
est accueilli avec beaucoup d'amitié
beaucoup de chaleur par le président le
peuple français
en fait je n'ai pas fais très attention
à ces réactions alors elles ont été
alimentées ces réactions notamment par
une déclaration que vous avez fait il ya
quelques jours à lisbonne où vous avez
indiqué qu'il était normal pour les pays
pauvres d'avoir recours au terrorisme
est ce que vous justifier le terrorisme
n'ont jamais dit cela je n'ai jamais dit
que les pays pauvres devaient recourir
au terrorisme
je crois qu'il ya une très grande des
formations de mes propos déclarations
sont enregistrés c'était au cours d'une
conférence à l'université de lisbonne
donc vous avez le son et l'image
moussavi en france votre votre nom et le
nom de la libye reste pour beaucoup
associé aux attentats de lockerbie ou du
niger contre un avion français
alors on sait que des agents libyens ont
été condamnés et que les victimes de ces
attentats ont été indemnisées est ce que
cela signifie que vous considérer
aujourd'hui que ces attentats ont été
une faute ou un crime
la démo tour mobimo
il y a des gens qui ont été accusés qui
ont été condamnées pour ces affaires il
ne s'agit pas de l'état libyen il s'agit
d'individus à des faut-il rendre
coupable un état pour tous les crimes
commis par ces citoyens qui reconnaît
avoir frappé les états unis et citoyens
d'un état alors est-ce que son pays doit
assumer ses actes l'état ne peut pas
assumer la responsabilité de ce que
commettent les individus et c'est le cas
de la libye la libye et n'a jamais
commis d'acte terroriste
le président nicolas sarkozy a indiqué
hier qu'il vous avait demandé de
progresser sur le chemin des droits de
l'homme est ce qu'un jour on peut
s'attendre en libye à avoir des partis
politiques libres et une presse libre
tout d'abord nous n'avons pas évoqué moi
et le président sarkozy ces sujets nous
sommes amis et proches collaborateurs
ça n'a pas été évoqué
pas du tout absolument pas nous avons
évoqué les questions de coopération
entre les deux pays
nous avons évoqué tous ses contrats dans
différents domaines et dans l'intérêt
des deux pays
nous avons parlé de la coopération droit
africaine de l'union hésiter rannée end
aujourd'hui la question des droits de
l'homme ne se pose pas la libye est
arrivé à bon port en instaurant la
démocratie populaire directe
il n'y a pas d'élections en libye parce
que les libyens ne lisent pas leurs
dirigeants ce sont les libyens qui se
dirigent te mets à l'erreur mais il ya
aussi des prisonniers politiques en
libye
non non il n'y a pas de prisonniers
politiques en libye
qui a dit ça celui qui prétend cela
qu'ils se rendent en libye et qu'ils
cherchent
il n'y a pas un seul prisonnier
politique en libye est-ce qu'on peut
critiquer mouammar kadhafi en libye
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on a le droit les
nénés quoi voulez-vous qu'on critique
moi je ne dirige rien je n'ai pas le
pouvoir pas de compétences politiques ou
administratifs et le peuple qui gère ses
affaires
c'est lui qui détermine et loi et qui
prend les décisions
une toute dernière chose est ce que
cette visite en france marque selon vous
une nouvelle étape dans la marche de la
libye vers le concert des nations le
fait qu'elle retrouve sa pleine place
dans le monde
nous sortons d'une période de libération
nationale partout dans le monde et la
libye à participer à cette lutte contre
des forces étrangères qui apportaient
leur appui au racisme et au colonialisme
lui de cette confrontation maintenant
terminé avec succès
nous sommes dans une autre phase
nous avons affaire à une nouvelle
génération de dirigeants de renault
aujourd'hui nous nous rencontrons d'égal
à égal
nous espérons que le passé ne reviendra
jamais sommes déterminés à participer à
un nouveau monde de paix de liberté et
de coopération entre les nations et les
civilisations mon modèle voilà pour
cette interview enregistrée ce matin
donc et dont vous pouvez voir
l'intégralité sur le site france2 point
fr à noter que le secrétaire général de
l'elysée claude guéant assure que
nicolas sarkozy a bien parlé des droits
de l'homme à mouammar kadhafi à deux
reprises lors de leurs entretiens que
lors du dîner journée était le témoin
dit il
on passe à l'actualité sociale avec la
confusion sur une éventuelle grève cette
semaine dans les transports publics
en fait la cgt vient de lever
officiellement le préavis pour
après-demain jeudi à la sncf à la ratp
le préavis est toujours en place mais la
cgt est décidée à mener des actions qui
ne gênerait pas trop les usagers
séverine lebrun frédéric basket
les bus qui roulent des rames à peu près
à l'heure demain les usagers parisiens
peuvent compter sur 80 % de métro 90% de
bus et de tramways et le rer a sera
légèrement perturbé 60% des rer b
circuleront des prévisions revues à la
hausse car la cgt la seule organisation
qui appelait à la grève a finalement
changé d'avis
elle note des avancées sur le montant
des pensions et sur le calendrier
du coup elle s'en tiendra à des
débrayages la question ce n'est pas de
faire de cette journée de domaine
démonstration de force pour une
démonstration de force
on n'a pas vocation à faire grève au
niveau de la cgt ont la vocation à peser
dans la négociation
a la sncf on va de rebondissement en
rebondissement après une réunion de
conciliation la cgt vient tout juste
d'annoncer qu'elle renonçait à la grève
jeudi
quelques heures plus tôt la cgc le
syndicat des cadres avaient fait de même
la direction a lâché du lest en
proposant de prolonger la négociation
jusqu'au mois de février
a priori les trains rouleront donc
normalement jeudi à propos de grève le
gouvernement l'avait laissé entendre le
ministre de l'éducation xavier darcos
souhaite le réaliser dès la rentrée 2008
il y aura bien un service minimum
d'accueil dans les écoles
les discussions sont en cours pour cela
avec les communes car ce sont elles qui
gèrent le primaire
les syndicats eux sont très réservés mme
alors yahoo nous servait poteau un
centre de loisirs pour les enfants
privés d'école lors de la dernière grève
des enseignants la mairie d'antony avait
ainsi assuré une sorte de service
d'accueil minimum un accueil que
réclament les familles pour les parents
qui travaillent ça me paraît très
important ça évite de se creuser la tête
pour trouver un mode de garde
ce matin le ministre de l'éducation a
annoncé vouloir développer ses pratiques
je propose que les communes
organise cet accueil melrose elles sont
volontaires et que je vienne concourir à
financer les dépenses que les mairies
auront eu à cette occasion comme
toulouse plusieurs villes ont déjà
répondu présent
sous certaines conditions les choses
doivent être très clair il faut que
lesdites ajout franc jeu il faut pas que
l'état nous demande de faire quelque
chose et puis n'en payent pas le prix le
gouvernement prévoit en fait de reverser
aux municipalités les retenues sur
salaires des enseignants grévistes les
syndicats s'étonnent
s'il ya de l'argent à distribuer aux
communes il vaudrait mieux d'abord faire
en sorte qu'on ait davantage
d'enseignants dans les écoles davantage
de dispositifs on mettre les élèves en
difficulté que de se lancer dans un
dispositif genre gina gaz qui nous
paraît fort peu efficace les professeurs
craignent surtout que le projet ne
limite leur droit de grève
les discussions devraient s'engager dans
les semaines à venir pour restaurer cet
accueil minimum dès la rentrée 2008
en bref cette bonne nouvelle sur le
front de l'emploi selon les statistiques
trimestrielles qui sont désormais la
règle le taux de chômage est passé sous
la barre des 8% 7,9 pour cent de la
population active très exactement contre
8,1 pour cent au deuxième trimestre ça
ne concerne que la france métropolitaine
l'actualité économique encore si vous
faites partie des 10 millions de
personnes qui vivent en hlm
alors vous êtes directement concernés
c'est un changement des règles
d'attribution qu'a annoncé nicolas
sarkozy tout à l'heure en visite dans
l'est de la france
il estime que ces logements doivent être
prioritairement réservé aux plus
modestes
la situation financière des locataires
sera donc réexaminée tous les trois ans
ceux qui dépassent les plafonds devront
partir ou payer un supplément
lorsque j'ai refait les purs peau en
france plus de 4 millions de logements
sociaux pourtant un million et demi de
foyers sont en liste d'attentes pour y
accéder alors comment faire pour le
gouvernement il faut inciter les
familles qui n'ont plus de raison d'y
habiter à laisser leur place
et pour ça une annonce choc
désormais la situation de chaque ménage
devra être réexaminée tous les trois ans
pour envisager soit maintien dans le
logement soit un relogement dans un
logement plus adapté au sein du parc
social
soit un parcours d'accession à la
propriété objectifs sinon leur faire
payer un surloyer proportionnelles à
leurs revenus selon les organismes hlm 1
5 % des logements serait habité par des
familles dépassant le plafond de
ressources selon gouvernement il serait
le double vie pour ça des logements
sociaux il y en a partout dans ces
logements hlm du 16e arrondissement de
paris
les réactions sont contrastées sur
évidemment contre puisque c'est une
dépense supplémentaire
lille est pas logique si vous voulez que
des gens habitants des hlm et reste dans
les hlm alors que leurs revenus
augmentent
parmi les mesures confirmées accéder à
la propriété en achetant son logement
hlm une priorité pour le président de la
république en 2006 seulement 6000
logements ont été vendus alors que
l'objectif est de 40 mille par an le
produit des ventes devrait permettre
alors de construire de nouveaux
logements la justice avec un
rebondissement dans la sphère des deux
enfants tués à montigny-lès-metz en 1986
francis heaulme le fameux tueur en série
devrait bénéficier d'un non lieu
c'est ce qu'a requis le parquet c'est
l'une des grandes énigmes judiciaires de
ces dernières années qui revient sur le
devant de la scène
il faut rappeler qu'un autre homme
patrick dils avait été condamné pour ces
faits puis finalement acquitté parce que
le dossier semblait est accablant
justement pour francis heaulme dorothée
cochard jacques gérard
pour le procureur de la république il
n'y a pas assez de preuves contre
francis zone
pas d'aveux aucune preuve formelle du
crime des deux enfants de 8 ans
alexandre et cyril retrouvé mort le long
de la voie ferrée de montigny-lès-metz
avait comme un tueur en série déjà
condamné pour neuf meurtres la justice
croyait pourtant tenir son probable
d'autant que le jour de la
reconstitution et confirmera qu'il était
bien présent ce jour de septembre 86 et
qu'il a même vu les deux enfants morts
les enfants tués à coups de pierres les
gendarmes sont alors convaincu de sa
culpabilité pas le procureur de la
république
il a requis un non-lieu nous ne pouvons
que constater hélas l'insuffisance des
charges susceptibles de peser à
l'encontre de francis heaulme un
non-lieu pour rôle après un acquittement
pour 10 patrick dils condamné puis
acquitté par la justice en 2002 après 15
en prison patrick dils que la famille du
jeune alexandre a toujours cru coupable
il a été condamné deux fois il a donné
des détails terrible on ne peut pas
partir a déchiré sa émettra dans la
poubelle
une position qui confinent à
l'acharnement selon l'avocat de patrick
dils
j'ai du mal à comprendre que les
familles poursuit de lorraine patrick
dils sachant qu'il a fait 16 ans de
prison et que c'est déjà une peine
extrêmement lourde pour un coupable a
fortiori pour un innocent la loi
interdit de toute façon la révision d'un
acquittement
le juge d'instruction a déjà laissé
entendre qu'il suivrait les réquisitions
du parquet la justice se retrouvera donc
vingt ans après les fêtes avec un double
crime sans coupable
il ya vraiment de quoi être désorientés
par la justice bonsoir dominique
verdeilhan vous nous avez rejoint car
l'histoire n'est vraiment pas banal non
c'est un séisme judiciaire dont on vient
de vivre une réplique une secousse c'est
presque une justice d'un autre âge d'un
autre siècle cette affaire nous ramène
21 ans en arrière à une époque où la
police scientifique était à ses
balbutiements
à une époque où les juges ne disposait
pas d'un outil aujourd'hui presque
imparable adn alors la sphère de
montigny-lès-metz ce sont d'abord des
aveux assez précis puis rétractées vous
l'avez dit de patrick dils
c'est ensuite la conviction d'un
gendarme qui fait entrer 1
deuxième homme la quasi signature
criminelle de francis heaulme pour
reprendre l'expression de l'enquêteur
alors aujourd'hui pas de charge pas
d'éléments matériels donc impossibilité
d'un renvoi devant la cour d'assises
alors c'est désastreux à plus d'un titre
d'abord pour les familles des victimes
ensuite pour patrick dils qui n'est pas
déchargés du soupçon
ensuite pour la justice qui dans cette
affaire risque d'être la seule à être
condamnée pour faute lourde
merci dominique la justice encore en
bref une confrontation générale avait
lieu aujourd'hui avait lieu aujourd'hui
dans l' affaire clearstream
elle a réuni nos mimiques de villepin
jean louis gergorin et le général
philippe rondot de source judiciaire on
indique que l'ancien premier ministre
s'est parfois trouver en contradiction
avec les versions concordantes des deux
hommes
et puis sachez que pierre pasqua fils de
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur charles
pasqua a été condamné à un an et demi de
prison ferme dans un dossier de
commissions occultes
l'homme d'affaires pierre falcone a été
condamné à un an ferme il y aura appel
images signées pascal caron à un moment
de répit et de bonne humeur au sommet de
bali sur les changements climatiques les
participants ont célébré le dixième
anniversaire des accords de kyoto avec
cet énorme gâteau kyoto vous le savez
concerne ces accords ratifiés par 36
pays industrialisés pour tenter de
limiter les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre à propos d'environnement les
derniers progrès du compost
il s'agit de recycler le maximum
d'ordures ménagères
certaines communes sont en pointe c'est
le cas de saint philbert de bouaine en
vendée où tout le monde se sent concerné
reportage edouard baer jan annick
rivoire
éplucher les légumes c'est le début de
la recette du pot-au-feu et déjà il y a
des déchets des déchets organiques
ils représentent plus du quart de notre
poubelle et sont recyclables en compost
depuis cinq ans cette famille trie les
déchets verts dans le bac vert vous avez
et marc de café
des fleurs qu'est-ce qu'on a des
mouchoirs papier des séries de papier
saint philbert de bouaine un bourg
vendéen de 3000 habitants ici 86% de la
population à adopter le compostage la
maison de retraite et les restaurants
compris depuis 2002 et le refus d'un
centre d'enfouissement des déchets sur
la commune on joue collectif
une plateforme de compostage voit le
jour tenu par des bénévoles ouvert trois
fois par semaine
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes un
français jette en moyenne 400 kg
d'ordures par an à saint philbert ce
poids est ramenée à 135 kilos voilà je
tamponne la carte de fidélité ça donne
le droit du compost
deux fois par an à peu près et on pèse
pour avoir un suivi statistique du
terreau gratuit moins de poubelles à
collecter et une économie de 50 euros
par an pour cette famille car ici plus
l'habitant produit de déchets plus la
taxe d'ordures et cher et en plus chacun
met la main à la pâte
c'est pour les autres
moi je suppose comme ça si tout le monde
pour tout le monde le fasse après un
maître composteur s'occupe du centre et
contrôler la fermentation des déchets là
il ya pas loin de 70 degrés donc ces
conditions optimales pour le
développement des bactéries l'activité
l'intérieur du compost quatre mois plus
tard on obtient de l'humus qui servira
d'engrais pour le jardin produit par la
terre le compost retourne à la terre
sans dépense d'énergie et sans pollution
pour l'environnement la santé
l'interdiction totale de fumer dans les
lieux publics y compris dans les bars et
restaurants entrera en vigueur vous le
savez le 1er janvier donc dans trois
semaines exactement depuis un an ceux
qui souhaitent s'arrêter de fumer
dispose d'une nouvelle molécule la rare
et nicklin il s'agit d'un médicament
prescrit sur ordonnance et qui
représente aujourd'hui un quart des
ventes des traitements dead à l'arrêt du
tabac
laurence beauvillard thierry breton
camille a déjà essayé d'arrêter de fumer
plusieurs fois elle à tester les gommes
les patchs les médicaments rien n'a
fonctionné
elles fumaient un paquet par jour
jusqu'à ce qu'elle prenne un nouveau
traitement
c'est un arrêt progressif d'un paquet au
bout de quinze jours j'étais si
cigarettes par jour et en quinze jours
après j'avais totalement arrêtée camille
a pris de la varénicline son action est
très différente des autres traitements
la nicotine se fixe sur des récepteurs
qui déclenche la sensation du plaisir
avec la varénicline ces récepteurs sont
occupé et bloqué si le patient continue
à fumer
la nicotine ne peut pas se fixer il y a
donc ni manque ni plaisir
ce traitement par la loi ni clean est un
traitement de trois mois qu'on peut
prolonger trois mois supplémentaires
quand on juge nécessaire et c'est
évidemment pas le seul
la seule efficacité de la molécule qui
fait arrêter les gens de fumer
il faut les accompagner il faut qu'ils
aient envie de poursuivre trois mois de
traitement coûte 300 euros avec une
prise en charge maximum de 50 euros
autre réserve malgré l'efficacité de ce
produit à court terme
un an après trois fumeurs sur quatre ont
repris la cigarette
direction londres maintenant la plus
grande ville britannique est devenue en
quelques années la capitale de l'argent
fou elle compte 68 milliards d'eur il
faut savoir que jamais dans le monde les
très grandes fortunes n'ont été aussi
nombreuses
dernier arrivé et les plus nombreux
aujourd'hui les russes c'est le dossier
de cette édition il est signé maryse
burgot dominique marault ten 130000
euros par an c'est le prix d'un
abonnement à cette compagnie de jets
privés basé à londres
une bagatelle pour cette femme qui
revient d'une journée de shopping à
genève et qui préfère ne pas être
interviewés
extrêmement discret de plus en plus de
milliardaires venus du monde entier soit
this de résider dans la capitale
britannique
mais ils se cachent derrière des
intermédiaires ici ils donnent leurs
ordres par téléphone lors de cette vente
aux enchères de tableaux russe chez
sotheby's
ils ne sont pas dans la salle mais ils
font flamber le marché
de quoi dégoûter cet aristocrate russe
qui est un vrai amateur d'art les au
geste est le plus cher
comme ils ne comprennent pas
chaque réseau les moyens si de tels
mandats c'est qu'il n'y a pas de beaux
endroits où le voir tellement de gens
avec tellement d'argent londres capitale
des taxis noirs mais aussi des bentley
maserati et autres rolls royce new look
460 mille euros pour ce cabriolet et
deux ans de listes d'attentes le marché
du luxe ne suis tout simplement pas la
demande
nous avons 80 commandes à satisfaire et
ces gens attendent depuis 2004 ce
journaliste publie chaque année la liste
de ces milliardaires qui choisissent
londres parce que c'est un paradis
fiscal
ils jouissent d'un statut fiscal de non
domicilié très intéressant il ne paye
pas un drapeau surtout steve gagne à
l'étranger c'est un peu la suisse au
bord de la tamise
le gouvernement britannique dorlote donc
ces grandes fortunes qui booste des pans
entiers de l'économie
l'immobilier par exemple 9 millions
d'euros pour cet appartement pas une
résidence principale non juste un
pied-à-terre idéal pour un oligarque
russe fils paye cash
c'est comme si la chair bijoux et le
veulent ils l'achètent sur le champ le
plus connu de ces milliardaires installé
à londres est peut-être le russe
abramovitch
il s'est offert le club de foot de
chelsea mais il n'accorde jamais
d'interview fidèle à cette devise
pour vivre heureux vivons cachés retour
en france vous l'avez peut être constaté
si vous habitez les régions concernées
la neige est tombée en abondance ces
dernières heures météo france émet
d'ailleurs un bulletin d' alerte aux
avalanches
même dans les alpes du sud images ici de
sainte anne la condamine on n'avait pas
vu ça depuis plus de 10 ans chute de
neige importante aussi dans les vosges
le jura et les pyrénées voilà qui nous
amène aux courses de noël avec les
derniers des mohicans oui il reste
encore en france une fabrique une seule
de peluches même si la plupart d'entre
elles sont maintenant
confectionné en asie ultime créneau pour
cet atelier la qualité et même le luxe
près de châteauroux dans l'indre
reportage à n'diaye paix fabien tormos
tout juste terminée grand front grandes
oreilles
un ours typiquement blanche et comme il
s'en fabrique depuis 50 ans il a été
entièrement découpé à la main incroyable
aujourd'hui mais indispensable les poils
longs ça qu'on ferait le point à la
machine qui coupe le point et ses
ouailles et le pôle il n'est pas coupée
au catalogue 400 modèles réalisés dans
des imitations fourrure haut de gamme
ici on travaille encore avec les
machines traditionnelles pour une faute
une solide réalisée avec soin bonjour
toujours de ciseaux en dans la main tout
le temps on ça la culture se voit fera
constate nous dans notre magasin du sinn
des jeunes viennent chez nous parce que
ils veulent acheter de la qualité et
avoir quelque chose de différent de ce
qui est dans les grandes surfaces ou de
skier dans les grandes chaînes mais la
petite entreprise familiale a subi de
plein fouet la concurrence asiatique
il ne reste plus que 11 salariés elles
étaient 80 il ya trente ans pour
continuer à vendre à nos sources plus
chère elle mise sur la peluche sur
mesure nombreux des choix de la couleur
il faut plein les yeux bleus ce qui a
séduit le nouveau propriétaire un
célèbre magasin de jouets parisien un
ours commandait le l'asie arrive chez
nous le mardi ou mercredi
pour nous c'est un aéropage à paris le
nounours blanche et se vend entre 80 et
400 euros parfois beaucoup plus cher
pour les grands modèles le nounours made
in france devenue jouet de luxe pour
survivre cinéma vous vous souvenez sans
doute de la marche de l'empereur qui
avait remporté un oscar il ya quelques
années bien luc jacquet le réalisateur
revient avec un nouveau film qui sort
demain le renard et l'enfant
le récit d'un apprivoisement mutuelle
marie-jo jouant jean-marie lequertier
l'histoire est simple et magique à la
fois c'est la rencontre entre une petite
fille et un renard racontée par isabelle
carré gharnata toute vitesse
juste ici pour se dépenser pour le petit
phrase de saint-exupéry et son renard
apprivoisé et la surprise de découvrir
un bestiaire merveilleux en france au
coeur même des montagnes de l'ain
étaient là de voir tout ce qui
d'habitude nous échappe tout ce qu'on
rêve de voir quand on se balade et qu'on
ne voit jamais ou alors en passant un
animal de loin comme ça très très très
subrepticement mais là on va au plus
près on sent même sa respiration lui son
petit caillou côté vu avant de trouver
la perle rare berti 11 ans une fillette
des villes pas vraiment familier avec
les animaux heureusement les cinq renard
du film était apprivoiser
damman content d'être avec lui et oublie
la caméra tu étais bien avec lui c'est
pas pour la caméra que tu fais c'est
pour lui c'est pour toi et pour mu ont
travaillé avant pour jouer bonjour tu
travailles je passais mes journées à
apprendre à lire écrire et compter
j'étais même pas capable de retrouver la
trace de 6 dans la marche de l'empereur
huljack et filmer la réalité de la vie
des manchots le réalisateur se sert ici
de tous les moyens techniques du cinéma
le renard et l'enfant est une vraie
fiction inspiré de son enfance je me
suis maître envie de mettre nos points
de vue d'adulte à la fois qui transmet à
ses enfants l'envi de la nature mais
aussi mon envie de 2,2 me pencher sur
cette question de l'eau du rapport entre
l'homme et la nature entre l'homme et
l'animal
que signifie l'apprivoisement
apprivoiser pourquoi pas respecté
surtout dénaturer non le discours de luc
jacquet est sûrement inspiré par ce
regard avant de refermer cette édition
je vous en rappelle l'une des
principales informations alger replonge
dans le terrorisme aveugle et de masse
deux attentats simultanés à la voiture
piégée ont fait entre 22 et 62 morts
la branche locale d'al qaïda est montrée
du doigt par les autorités
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
nathalie rihouet 20h50 vous retrouver
paix à triesenberg pour un nouveau
numéro exceptionnel des sens qui font
bouger la france changer la vie les
femmes avec entre autres anne lauvergeon
ségolène royal isabelle carré et
beaucoup d'autres à demain
c'est l'info en continu c'est aussi sur
trousses de point fr